wins against von forest which is pretty
big in the scheme of things yeah and how
did eric hansen sorry i'm just saying
look because obviously eric was bouncing
back wasn't he into the tournament yeah
he's uh he's still playing still playing
okay right oh really 10 cent game there
against prague maybe fizzling out to a
draw
meanwhile magnus he's forced the black
king out of the corner that's the first
step now the black king not blockading
in the dark square in the corner
i think it's move 68 i mean resigning
designing here would not be a bad option
i feel you're playing magnus cast in the
mean light you know
almost stalemate though if the black
rook wasn't on the board it would be a
draw and stalemate but the problem is
you can't give up your black rook and uh
i mean you can't force white to take
your black work and i think we're about
to see vidi has he just resigned he has
done 68 move 68. well done so 69 was
would have been a great a great answer
there for 68 yeah
and uh yeah magnus showing his class
taking the endgame win